Let's quickly check if we understood
the write-update optimizations.
Suppose that we have a system with two
cores that uses write-update coherence.
Suppose that the two cores are executing
a program where core 0 writes something
to a memory address A, then core
1 reads it and this continues so
that the write and then a read pattern
repeats, for a total of 1,000 times.
So this is the first of 1,000.
After they do this for 1,000 times,
these cores go to do something else,
where core 0 replaces A and
then core 1 also replaces A.
The question for you is,
how many bus uses do we see when
the system uses no optimizations?
So there is no dirty bit and
no shared bit.
When the system uses only
the dirty bit optimization, and
when the system uses both the dirty and
the shared bit optimization.
So for each of these,
how many bus uses do we get during
this whole time for block A?
And also, how many memory writes do
we get in each of these three cases?